los demócratas presentarán este lunes
ante la cámara de representantes- una
resolución para pedir al vicepresidente
saliente mike pence la invocación de la
enmienda 25 a quien le dan 24 horas para
contestar de no hacerlo los legisladores
demócratas pasarán a activar un juicio
político contra donald trump según la
presidenta de la cámara baja nancy
pelosi al proteger nuestra constitución
y nuestra democracia actuaremos con
urgencia porque este presidente
representa una amenaza inminente para
ambos a medida que pasan los días se
intensifica el horror del continuo
asalto a nuestra democracia perpetrado
por este presidente y también la
necesidad inmediata de actuar cada vez
son más las voces republicanas que se
unen en repudio al presidente saliente
de eeuu el domingo- patrick tú mi
senador por pensilvania se convirtió en
el segundo republicano en pedir la
renuncia de trump por incitación a la
insurrección bueno creo que la mejor
opción para nuestro país es que el
presidente renuncie y se vaya lo antes
posible
reconozco que puede que no sea probable
pero creo que sería lo mejor no parece
que exista la voluntad o el consenso
para ejercerlo
opción de la enmienda 25 y no creo que
haya tiempo para hacer un juicio
político
quedan 10 días antes de que el
presidente se vaya de todos modos creo
que lo mejor sería una renuncia
tú me se suma así a la senadora por
alaska lisa murkowski que ya había hecho
lo propio y a otro senador de nebraska
pensás que dijo que consideraría los
artículos de impeachment si la cámara
los aprueba tras recibir una oleada de
críticas la casa blanca hizo ondear la
bandera a media asta cinco días después
de la muerte del oficial bryant signis
el domingo fue homenajeado por sus
compañeros
una encuesta davis in you save se revela
que más de la mitad de los
estadounidenses quieren que el
presidente abandone el cargo antes del
20 de enero